general merrick garland got his butt
kicked
testifying before the senate today
garland repeatedly pressed over why he
refuses to rescind the justice
department's memo
sicking the fbi on parents even the
national school boards association
apologized
you're just a vessel aren't you
i'm not sure what you mean by that you
have weaponized the fbi and the
department of justice it's wrong it is
unprecedented to my knowledge in the
history of this country and i call on
you to resign this letter calls him a
domestic terrorist the nsba is so
embarrassed of this letter they've
apologized for it and retracted it but
you don't apparently have the same
willingness to apologize and retract
what you did this testimony your
directive your performance is shameful
okay that's nice thank god you are not
on the supreme court
you should resign in disgrace judge
that was painful that was terrible yes
garland also grilled about
if he is now finally aware of the
loudoun county school rape case
you indicated in response to that that
you weren't aware of that
and in the six days before you testified
before the house judiciary committee
um
have you become familiar with the
publicly reported details of that case
yes i have read about the case yes
well that's good game over all right
martha what stood out to you uh how was
his performance
so i mean i don't think you can say the
name eric garland without thinking about
the history here right and tom cotton
brought up the supreme court and at that
time he was seen as this person who was
so wronged because he wasn't even given
the opportunity to have a hearing now
you can argue that he should have had it
either way but everyone sort of expected
i think as attorney general that he was
going to be this extremely even-handed
and very careful attorney general the
problem for merrick garland right now is
that the sequence of events here makes
it look otherwise right so you've got
the the national school board
association sends out this memo and then
you get the back story on that and oh
they've been going back and forth with
the white house you know we're really
upset about these crazy things that are
happening at these meetings and we think
that you know people are are under
assault or they're in danger and
literally over the weekend
you know from friday the letter goes out
monday there's a there's an announcement
that the fbi is going to be watching all
of this so it just makes it now under
scrutiny and questioning merrick garland
goes well i based it on the letter from
the national school board association
which by the way they've now walked back
on the language in and
reports that i read in the media that
that an investigation that does not make
you don't have to be a lawyer to
understand that you need to and i
remember even when i read this the first
moment it said you know that there had
been a dangerous spike i was like what's
well let's see like where's the
dangerous spike let's see these examples
what is actually what's actually
happening that merits is kind of
response from the department of justice
not just the local law enforcement so
it's been a really really tough uh
couple of hearings from eric garland you
know katie we've seen so many hearings
this this to me is something that is
pretty damn serious but does it fall
into that world of drama like where oh
the republicans act this way and then
then it just goes away right like it's
just it's just drama for the sake of
drama do we get anywhere well based on
what merrick garland said today and not
rescinding the doj memo i don't think
that it's going away and i think that
the justice department under orders from
the white house and president biden want
this to continue and for these school
boards to continue to be monitored and
the problem for the department of
justice is especially under democrat
presidents they have no credibility when
it comes to telling parents that the fbi
is not coming after you after all the
irs colluded with doj to go after the
tea party movement in 2010 were regular
people in their community just like
parents going to their school board
meeting they worked in 2016 with the fbi
to falsify fisa warrant applications
which were granted by the fisa court and
now they're supposed to just take the
word of the attorney general who's
directed by the white house that
everything's going to be fine even
though the letter from the national
school boards association has been
repealed
he didn't have a basis to go do this in
the first place and now the letter's
been taken back he really has no basis
to do it and then the other thing is and
he was asked about this today if you're
focused on parents at school board
meetings you're not focused on other
things that are actually your job like i
don't know he was asked about
afghanistan today and what he's doing to
manage the threat from al-qaeda or isis
k and he said that he didn't really know
what they were doing so that's a problem
and it puts americans at risk raw though
he didn't seem that prepared for this or
over he seemed overwhelmed well i think
that overwhelmed us closer to the truth
first of all he's an eminent jurist he
was the great
circuit court judge appellate federal
appellate judge
he should have had in martha's uh
recounting he should have had a hearing
he should have been
on the supreme court of the united
states if obama got a fair shake he got
screwed but watching him because he got
caught he got caught you know
politicizing the doj
and a very very unfortunate case i don't
know what was his incentive and why he
did it in that rush manner over the
weekend but it was uh it was lame that
he did it but i have to say
watching ted cruz and josh harley
they're so nasty so snarly they make my
skin crawl it really is the way they
were so
so disrespectful and tom cotton uh you
know that attack just now that doesn't
make tom cotton look like a like a like
a real uh
a serious senator that looks like a an
ideological warrior trying to score a
cheap point do you think that was bad i
do remember the kavanagh hearings are
all no i don't
they were getting back at merrick
garland who had nothing to do with the
kavanaugh hearings in a way that trumped
you know what you can use the verb
it makes my screen call for the doj to
be politicized to go after everyday
parents for daring to question their
schools
what if the children watching the senate
in action it was jimmy stewart you know
we've seen a lot worse from the senate i
don't know
katie's right imagine you're the new
attorney general you go and you meet
with the fbi team and you think about
your threat matrix when you're coming in
what do we have to worry about
sex trafficking gun trafficking chinese
espionage isis sympathizers
counterfeiters corporate fraudsters but
no a lib sends a letter to the attorney
general and he says aha
we're gonna sick the fbi on angry
parents in just two days he gets it's
the fastest the government's ever worked
they turned it right around like the fbi
doesn't have enough people to frame to
begin with so and then the letter blows
up yeah and instead of just dropping it
he continues the fbi task force now what
does this remind you of it reminds me of
when the dossier was determined early to
be bunk and they continued to use it to
spy on trump now i think we need to
thank cocaine mitch for blocking this
guy's nomination i say that lovingly
because if this guy had gotten on the
court i mean what a puppet he is such a
puppet of the radical left and he's dumb
he's not articulate geraldo he couldn't
answer a single question he's a dumb
puppet and he's a corrupt puppet because
his family makes money for pushing crt
and he used the fb be careful
he has a son-in-law who is a
tangentially involved son-in-law that
means his daughter is getting rich
that's how things work geraldo all right
so
instead of saying you know what let me
run this up the flagpole at justice to
see if the lawyers think this says
ethical ted cruz asked him flat out did
you run this by anybody couldn't answer
the question and that's why this country
doesn't trust these people if you're not
stranding them in afghanistan if you're
not getting them fired from a job you're
basically sending the fbi after them
because they want to stick up for their
kids it looks like he melted in that
scene if this letter was about antifa or
blm never would have happened exactly so
if you're waiting for an siv uh way out
of afghanistan and you've been waiting
for nine months you see that this
happens in 96 hours you're going really
yeah really
all right